wir könnten dieses deathmatch jetzt echt
einfach mal ohne einen einzigen def
beenden
wie krass wie es geht und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft jump league wir spielen heute
in einem ganz besonderen setup denn ich
bin wie ihr vielleicht am klackern und
klappern hört nicht ganz alleine
ich habe heute besuch von einem reporter
von einer regionalzeitung hier und er
beobachtet mich so ein bisschen verfolgt
mich so ein bisschen sind verfolgt mich
nicht begleitet mich ein bisschen beim
dreh und das richtige setup ich habe ja
im rahmen des burger bett ist eine
regionale bei mir so ein interview
gegeben und dann kamen dann kann man auf
mich zu und meinte so ja da wird mir
gern ein bisschen mehr machen also bis
in unserer etwas für etwas ältere diego
bei youtube vorstellen und wie seit
jahren mache ich gerne ein bisschen
wissen vermitteln ja und jetzt haben wir
jetzt hier genau auf besuch im aufnahme
zimmer und ja ich nehme einfach auf so
spontan so also bis jetzt hier nicht
sein ernst warum warum hat das jetzt
nicht gezählt alte kam horn fitz ggf mit
meinem aus diesem ausnahme hier liegt so
auf ich brauche dringend ein mousepad
die ganze zeit hose vom laser deswegen
spinnt die so sollt ich hab kein geld
spendet werden ausführlich aber ich
sollte mir nicht mein ding ja keine
ahnung
es ist auf jeden fall eine sehr sehr
lustige szene leute ich werde euch das
auch sehr gerne mal verlinken wenn der
artikel dann draußen ist da könnte ich
das mal anschauen
soweit versuche ich einfach nein
lauf nicht runter dort wird übrigens
sollte was ich auch noch gerne erzählen
darf ich war am sonntag in stuttgart und
habe das abo special da gerade
abgehalten vergleich mit dem event für
make these
das war echt cool also habe ich wirklich
wirklich coole leute getroffen und es
war wie erwartet ein eis zu euch
kennenzulernen als zuschauer
das habe ich davor schon gesagt dass ich
das gerne bisschen persönlicher
gestalten möchte diese beziehung bisher
was ich packe meine kommentieren
und das ist ganz gut geklappt in
stuttgart wirklich sehr sehr gut
es war ein sehr schwieriger tag auch
wenn manche zuschauer schon sehr früh
daran und ich gar nicht gerechnet hatte
aber es war echt nice und vor allen
dingen mega lieb also dazu keine story
erzählen
wir haben dann auch echt den essens
alister probieren dürfen und zwar nicht
nur den essen soll das sondern auch den
konkurrenz burger und das wird das war
echt witzig also wir haben natürlich
bilder gemacht und so viele proben
darunter haben da interviews gemacht und
dann irgendwann durfte ich hinter die
theke und durfte hinter der theke wenn
man eigene bürger rausgeben zusammen mit
dem konkurrenz bürgern das war richtig
richtig witzig ich also ich durfte bei
mcdonald's hinter die theke und durfte
dann meinen leuten also mein den geld
den gewinner vom abo special dann meinen
eigenen bürger so austeilen das war echt
eine leiste sache steht allerdings ein
schwerer sprung hier ja genau und wie
kam die einfach zwei burger darum sonst
von ihr ich auch echt cool
und dann hab ich hab da verteilt hat
danach noch fotos gemacht und dann kam
ich an den tisch zurück nehmen wieder
saß und das war irgendwie acht leute
außer mir und die saßen da und ich kann
gar nicht mein burger aber ich hab ein
bisschen länger gebraucht wegen fotos
pipapo alles mögliche und isomatten so
ja wir haben auf dich gewartet mit dem
essen so dass wir wollten mit ihr ist
und ich so amerika lieb leute das fand
ich echt richtig süß von den pc ja geil
der doktor funktioniert und bei uns hier
über 10 grad erwartet
rcc sitzt nein ich bin das spritzgebäck
weg weg weg
ja hier jack davenport ich bin einfach
ein warlord leute
merkt euch das leg dich nicht mit devon
an ist besser für euch also ich muss
sagen stuttgart berechne kugel sache
dann abend zu hause ja übrigens leute
kann ich unterstelle vielleicht auch
noch mal sagen es wissen wahrscheinlich
auch noch nicht alle
ich wollte natürlich stuttgart auch
gerne filmen aber es ging nicht als
hätte ich kein spaziergang gemacht warum
weil ja völlig ja auch davor main berlin
war unter den tv-spot gedreht habe und
wir in berlin dann so extremem zeitdruck
war mit der abreise und thiago wo er
müsse jetzt sofort alles packen das sich
einfach in berlin
meine läge der hat liegenlassen jiji
jetzt kann ich momentan einfach keine
madox machen sonst hätte ich das gerne
für euch dokumentiert aber an dieser
stelle nochmal schöne grüße ladet ihr in
stuttgart dabei waren war wirklich cool
war wirklich gutes karma machen
so jetzt wie die zielgerade aus kurzer
kurzes update platz zwei platz drei
lukas kraeft ford dessen wort sein
was ist los mit dem werk glaub ich noch
nichts verstanden im leben so kam er so
wie geht es hier lang war ich dann nicht
so oft ich vermute mal so ja ganz
seltsam und kurze sprünge aber okay
checkpoint die logos jetzt komm jetzt
schwieriger
der parcours ist okay geht auch schon
mal gut los und jetzt bitte einmal kurz
durch last lasse mich durch zu der kiste
übrigens noch mal danke schön erläutert
alle leute die sich überhaupt beworben
haben bei mappus beispiel das war echt
cool
das waren unter dem video wirklich 400
kommentare also und extrem extrem viele
bewerbung war sehr nice schibsted
warum das ding hart ist weil man einfach
die ganze zeit die komischen
blöcke springer maximaldistanz was seid
ihr denn für opfer spamming z
obwohl jetzt gibt es einen rechtsstreit
diskussion alles klar
dj kicks ohne nehmen es mir nicht übel
ich spiele einfach ein bisschen ja jetzt
usa sehr schwach die kiste habe ich
schon okay und sehr schön ist das letzte
modul aber wir können auf jeden fall
aber vielleicht schaffen es doch
vielleicht schaut mir noch diese runde
zu beenden
es könnte reichen aber es wird nicht
leicht sind okay sein ja gut dass ich
nicht so hierüber aller welt ihrem gut
aufgeholt und hier gucke ich immer das
jahr an das ist aber so irritieren so
ein richtiger ronald weasley einfach
nachgebaut dankeschön
ja ja sehr schön dass er funktioniert
normalerweise habe ich hier richtig
große schwierigkeiten bei den part aber
gut es geht es geht schon mal es geht
als würde ich ein spezieller maria und
pc jetzt dass jetzt ein kleiner trick
job sehr gut geschafft checkpoint nice
alter wir können fast auf finnischen man
werde noch 55 sekunden für das letzte
modul bin deutscher mit russischem
migrationshintergrund zwei gefolgt aber
alles easy ob ich dann habe ich dieses
modul hier drüben überhaupt jemals schon
mal gespielt
ich bezweifle es stark ich war noch nie
so geht's über plan ich hoffe mal hier
es ist die kiste rüdiger sehr gut weg
wie ich vermute man jetzt hier geht's
raus ich kann so springen die leute was
da hinten ok denkt nein nein nein junge
okay das war's das war es einfach so wie
habe ich den sprung krass unterschätzt
man ok als deathmatch
jetzt gehts abwärts gesagt wenn wir
schon den job nicht geschafft hat und
dann wollen wir wenigstens basieren okay
da vorne sie nicht so krass script ich
kann mir das ist eine gute gelegenheit
für den clean up hdj klima von kent
nicht wenn ja sarko dicke combo sehr
schön jetzt hier lukas graf hd oder hd
deshalb jedes gefährlich die auflösung
könnte mir gefährlich werden da kommt
wieder sehr schön gut okay okay okay
okay ich würde diese runde vielleicht
einfach mal mit drei leben beenden wenn
es für euch cool ist wär doch mal ganz
nett hier geht's nicht rein sagt gass
okay der aber nicht so gut zu können was
holen nämlich mit nämlich mit über die
registry verdient mit richard auch gutes
equipment sehr schön
sie läuft läuft läuft leute die jetzt
glaube ich schon 45 kills geholt und das
ohne ein einziges mal zu sterben denn
wir wollen ja jetzt nicht so nicht
zwischen zwischen die fronten geraten
ist dass die fronten geraten
wir holen uns den hier wieder sehr gut
okay nächster gegner ist hier hat
wahrscheinlich auch nie wieder drin ist
eine sonderbare nach einer junge was ist
los alter wie viele gegner noch einer
york wird jetzt dann halt du dich dann
raus alter kommt ok er hält sich nicht
raus leute was ist das alter setzt mich
nicht so unter druck
ja aber ich habe noch immer fünf teile
der krieg noch auf zwei etagen bekommen
formiert jetzt kurz blog hätten sehr
schönes weg sehr hohe alter diese runde
geht richtig ab man wenn ich hier welche
zwei kameras vor mir habt dann doch das
noch besser kommen
annette combo ist annette komme auf
jeden fall sehr schön gut
ich weiß nicht blockierten doch bringt
doch was weil diese runde blog hätte ich
echt sowas gibt es kein morgen mehr und
es läuft ja eigentlich ganz gut oder
nicht er nicht was findet ihr ist es ist
es vielleicht
so hier rechts das noch 212 leben hey
was geht
ok habe jetzt mal den weg und da glaube
ich jetzt mal den iren im combat close
combat blockhütten ja nicht wo wir
wollen leute denen ich würde gerne runde
gerne mit ihr bekommen ich hier bekommen
sie schießt einfach rein
er schreibt mir einfach lappen water
faktischer warum bildchen lappen wichtig
mit brille und den nächsten krieg auch
mit dem bau läuft sehr schön immer noch
34 / die doppelte regions und jetzt
close combat vielleicht kann ich
mitkommen schon mal einheit mehr als er
ja sehr gut kommt dann noch eine von dem
keiner so jetzt miteinander noch wir
könnten dieses deathmatch jetzt echt
einfach mal ohne einen einzigen def
beenden
wie krass wir das gucke ich mal meine
alten jazz plädiert ist 187 von 240 in
diesem bett manager die einfach schon 50
hughes points verloren
heftig man aber lieber jetzt geht's ab
jetzt geht's ab wir können auch gar
nicht fair machen
ich hab ja nichts für das kann ich ihnen
geben wenn damit es fair ist keine
eisenachs geben höhe
das schreibt er okay weißt du was ja wie
ich sagte okay da ist ich wollte endlich
gerade eisenachs trocken dann hinter
eisenachs alfabet durchzieht du heutiger
nähe okay gut 13 kills what the [ __ ] das
war einfach mein bestes match aller
zeiten
in joplin die leute okay weil ich das
gefallen hat dann lasst gerne einen
daumen nach oben da wir sehen uns im
nächsten video wieder haut rein macht's
gut
und haltet die augen offen nach der
story